what's the best way to lose weight um
the fastest way neither were listening
fastest way yeah I would say one meal a
day yeah let's say you're not super
active okay if you're if you're an
athlete if you're in the gym twice a day
hey no eat eat throughout the day
however most people tell me coach I
can't train I have this have kids have
it
okay so then do one meal a day just wake
up don't eat have your dinner one
regular meal and you'll lose weight and
you won't you won't have any health
problems you won't have any any
deficiencies just eat a healthy meal at
night one meal
see what happens after six months you're
not gonna be hungry until lunchtime
I'm sorry dinnertime you won't be hungry
morning lunch you won't be fasting maybe
fasting you absolutely some some people
fast 24 hours
some people fast 48 hours fasting is
extremely healthy for instance in 2016
they gave the Nobel Prize for the
discovery of autophagy autophagy look
I'm not a biologist but in layman's
terms I'm trying to do it as much
justice as I can basically if you don't
eat for a prolonged period of time your
body will start to eat the bad cells
okay I'm not gonna I don't know the I
don't recall the exact term but
basically there are cells that are
replicated that are replicated not
exactly okay there are they're bad cells
okay again please forgive the terms
these cells are digested eaten by the
body they're destroyed by the body if
there's no food coming in for a
prolonged period of time so that the
body will start to destroy eat those
cells first so I really recommend the
work of Jason funk Jason funk does a
tremendous amount of did a tremendous
amount of work on research on fasting
and he mentions autophagy in his work
and he even believes it cures cancer No
yeah what do you think of ketogenic
diets ketogenic diet is good for for
somebody who's not very active so
ketogenic diet for those who don't know
is you really limit your crabs to about
50 grams per day that will be the
average ok so 50 grams of carbs per day
so basically you're eating greens fats
and a little bit of protein mmm
you're not eating even fruits now it's
not bad because you're never spiking
your insulin so you're gonna start
losing fat I guarantee you if you do
ketogenic diet you're gonna lose fat
however
you lose ma so you won't be bulky okay
so for instance a lot of people you see
on Instagram YouTube these guys are on
steroids okay they're telling you
ketogenic diet it's not but they're on
steroids they don't tell you they're on
steroids but there aren't steroids
around Iran you know they'd bulk up
because the thing is when you eat
carbohydrates and you do spike your
insulin yes it makes your fat cells
bigger but it also makes your muscle
tissue bigger so for instance a lot of
ketogenic diet people who are on the
ketogenic diet they'll also eat carbs at
the right time so before they go lift
body build or they're spart they'll eat
rice those spike their insulin because
they need to feed that muscle and even
some will do it afterwards if they feel
they need to bulk up even more so they
eat rice before and after but because
you're exercising intensely you're
burning those carbohydrates very quickly
and then you're back into your Aikido
burning phase so for instance to put it
simply when you eat carbohydrates let's
call it rice bread potatoes your body
fills your glycogen reserves your
glycogen reserves it's think about that
the carpet the carbohydrates will go
into your muscle directly into your
muscle okay now there's an excess of
carbs then those carbs after all the
muscles are full of glycogen your body's
gonna turn that into fats okay forgive
the terms I'm not a biologist I'm just
giving you guys but in a nutshell we're
and taught okay yeah working with so
many nutrition experts mmm this is okay
look that's converted to fat if your
reserves in your muscles are depleted
you do you have no glycogen in your
muscle and you eat rice right before and
then you go train your body is gonna
prioritize that carbohydrate for the
intense training you're about to do and
to increase the muscle mass so it's
called carb timing your time your carb
is just right timing mm-hmm now look my
opinion this works I've done it it works
for me doesn't fit my lifestyle so what
I do is I eat my carbs in the morning
I my carbs at lunch I go train and then
I go to bed I don't need I don't I don't
eat any foods I just drink water so at
the end of the day my carbohydrate
levels are depleted when I wake up in
the morning I replenish them and I go to
train and then eat carbs in the
afternoon so me I eat my carbs in the
morning and we are unloading front
loading means I'm having my food early
in the day mm-hmm
why am i front loading because I'm
active during the day yeah if you take
two groups of people one group that eats
one meal a day at night and Jason funk
did this experiment okay he says look
one group ate their meal at night and
one group ate their one meal so their
only thing both groups are eating one
meal in 24 hours one eats it in the
afternoon the other one eats it at night
the one who ate it in the afternoon they
lost more weight why when you eat during
the day you have more energy so you're
gonna be more active so if I give you if
I give you they've done this experiment
as well take two groups one group we
give them carbohydrates one group we
don't give them carbohydrates we put
them keto both groups work out if the
keto group spends more energy they're
far more active so if we ask them do any
exercise they're gonna have more energy
the keto group is like lagging behind
and they need that's why even the keto
practitioners will eat carbs before
training they see the importance of
carbs the way I strategize it is to make
it really simple make my life more
simple biggest for me timing my food
right before practice and it's too
complicated
I eat my carbs in the morning I eat my
health natural foods in the morning I
eat my carbs in the morning then I have
my lunch and at 6 o'clock I stop eating
so I eat from 10:00 to 6:00 you're not
being Cubs or anything altogether just
water uh-huh that's why today I'm just
in drinking water right now if I want to
lose even more weight let's say okay now
it's I have to trim down a little more
I'll stop eating at 3:00 so I go eat
from 10:00 to 3:00
mmm for a while or not forever for a
while and then okay when I lean up okay
now I start feeding from 10:00 to 6:00
again mmm if I have a wedding or a
family get-together
I won't need 24 hours before so I when I
sit down when they offer me food I won't
be like no I can't eat so this diet
it fits my lifestyle yeah so I have like
when I go see my mother I have to eat
hmm when I take my family to go see my
mother she's gonna cook more than I can
eat you know like she's gonna my mom is
incredible you gotta eat you can't go
there now and say mmm tell us I can't
eat you have to eat so I know this I'm
only 24 hours before so I can eat and it
won't change my body composition that's
pretty straightforward I think a lot of
people would grasp that that's that's
very easy yeah ten to six or one meal
yeah if you have a special occasion yeah
24 hours don't need before that's it on
that note
does that go for your insights on so
many issues